Taylor Swift picture-perfect in pastel
at the 2019 time 100 gala 29 year old
singer was gorgeous in this pink and
yellow strapless
jaymund del gown with floral embroidery
and billowing sleeves she paired the
$7000 design with yellow Chloe Gosling
heels and Lorraine Schwartz jewelry
she's dead or is she alive and well
because this look is giving us major
vintage Taylor vibes think 2008 love
story era
[Music]
Seiler was on hand for the NYC event
because she's one of Time Magazine's 100
most influential people herself along
with Michelle Obama
BTS ariana grande Lady Gaga and many
more I'm so completely honored to get to
perform for this room of incredible very
influential human beings thank you so
much for wanting to like she even
performed her hit delicate at the
star-studded gala
[Music]
the outing comes just days before the 29
year old singer is set to release
something she started dropping hints
earlier this year about countdowns and
fans went nuts rumors started swirling
that a new album could be on the way Tay
Tay's even been seen out rocking what
looks to be ts7 merch see her name on
the sleeve now you cannot fangirl about
that whether it's a Bop for the summer
or an entire album fans are ready for it
and it will be here whatever it is
Friday April 26 are you ready for it oh
we're ready